ambiance rentrée des classes pour les 86
élus de dijon métropole beaucoup de
nouveaux visages
ils sont 47 a siégé pour la première
fois dans l'hémicycle sans grande
surprise le maire de dijon françois
rebsamen est réélu pour six ans par 61
voix contre 18
aux républicains emmanuel bichot
situation insolite
seul le nouveau maire de talant ne siège
pas dans cette assemblée
après sa victoire surprise face à adrian
genex sa propre tête de liste au bureau
mais c'est bien le candidat battu qui
siège comme conseiller métropolitain
conformément aux résultats des élections
là où il est important d'être 7 à la
métropole c'est le conseil métropolitain
aujourd'hui qui décident d énormément de
choses des travaux des grandes valeurs
des grandes infrastructures
c'est ici que se décident les choses je
pense que c'est important que talent
soit représentée par les gens qu'ils ont
appris qu'ils ont voté pour françois
rebsamen le début de la mandature sera
marquée par la gestion de l'après
qu'ovide quelles sont les conséquences
comment on peut juger et comment on peut
donner des perspectives en matière de
développement écologique d'innovation
pour faire une métropole qui soit
attractive solidaire et écologique
l'écologie le grand mot de son discours
d'investiture il annonce 2 millions
d'euros pour tripler les pistes cyclable
de l'agglomération
il affiche également l'ambition d'ici
dix ans de transformer dijon en
métropole capable de subvenir à
l'ensemble de ses besoins alimentaires
en renforçant l'agriculture urbaine et
les circuits courts